[Music]
now people have earned a reputation for
taking down industries and institutions
from Applebee's to breakfast cereal and
although many of these critiques are
exaggerated the effect that young people
have had on organized religion is
indisputable more than four and ten
young people are religiously
unaffiliated today it is the most common
religious identity among young adults
and a new survey suggests that these
religious changes may be permanent and
here's a couple of reasons why first
young people today were raised in less
religious homes growing up they were
less likely to attend religious services
say grace over dinner
or go to Sunday school the young adults
who've left their childhood religion are
also leaving early mostly during
adolescence in fact seventy percent
report having become religiously
unaffiliated before they turned eighteen
so a thirty year old who was
unaffiliated today has likely been that
way for over a decade finally due to the
rise of online dating and the sheer
number of secular romantic partners
secular couples have now become more
common reinforcing secular identity and
beliefs did you have a really just
upbringing let us know in our poll also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI